mais d'abord le vaccin astrazeneca
contre le coc vide 19 est il dangereux
l' agence européenne du médicament a
tranché tout à l'heure un lien possible
existe entre avec de très rares cas de
caillots sanguins très rares mais
suffisamment inquiétant pour que
certains patients s'en détournent et
préfèrent les nouveaux vaccinodromes ou
le finder est administrée voyez ce
reportage dans l'agglomération
tourangelle le lucas chopin les méga
centres de vaccination viennent d'ouvrir
en touraine et une question s'impose
déjà chez les patients de saint cyr sur
loire les petites questions qu'on en a
en général c'est quel vaccin est ce que
ses astra zeneca donc les gens sont
inquiets je leur dis que nous on a du
finder il ya pas mal de personnes qui
vont poser question
qui sont rassurés que ça s'appelle
astrazeneca même constat au centre de
saint-avertin ou leur est bien souvent à
la pédagogie
laurence alsac gère le lieu est il là
sur la mortalité liée au virus ne nous
permet pas de tourner le dos astrazeneca
il ya des craintes par rapport à lass
quinzaine et kashama juste rappeler que
c'est un risque sur 12 millions je
comprends que pour la personne qui a le
risque c'est du 100%
qui est cette crainte passé soixante dix
ans on est pratiquement sûr un risque
sur dix de décéder du coville ça ça
risque le réel le meilleur vaccin c'est
celui qu'on fait le plus rapidement
possible risque minime donc mais
défiance grandissante
ce qui provoque un effet inattendu
depuis hier dix rendez-vous vaccination
du docteur génisses ont été annulés soit
près de 20%
certains de nos patients qui ont
téléphoné nous ont précisé qu'ils
adulaient pour être vaccinés par le
kaiser au centre de vaccination de saint
cyr et on a montré un risque de
thrombose avec ce vaccin c'est vrai
enfin je pense qu'il faut pas le nier
mais que le nombre de cas est
anecdotique par rapport aux bénéfices
qu'on peut attendre d'une campagne
massive de vaccination
malgré les craintes l'efficacité du
vaccin reste avéré
l'agencé européenne du médicament assure
que la balance bénéfice risque reste en
faveur d'astrazeneca